all right
okay
what what time is the break
and then you're coming to us we're going
to be in the briefing by then you know
that right
i'll be sitting down in the briefing
though
all right
it's like people
[Music]
it should be back on the camera
oh we'll do it again
what is for me
like save me a trip back there there's
probably in the fridge
i don't know maybe
it's been a while yeah it feels like it
well enough last year
[Music]
is
it's going uh here
all right we'll see you next year nice
catching up
yes
[Music]
you're okay
oh no okay okay
briefing thank you
well we have a two minute warning so
one two three four five six seven eight
nine 10.
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten
you're right
yeah the white house says he is one
viewer who will not be turning into the
current or the former president's
impeachment trial that's happening they
say that's because
he's too busy focusing on his own agenda
here which of course is dealing with
that coronavirus
relief proposal that he is still trying
to make sure has all 50 democrats
on board with it in the senate as they
are drafting that legislation this week
in the house while the senate is of
course
focused on former president trump and so
the white house says he's going to be
doing that he's got a trip to the
pentagon
another to the national institutes of
health as well that's on his schedule
and so
they're going out of their way to say
this is not going to be something that
is taking up
a lot of time of president biden so of
course he has weighed in on it at times
he has declined to say
how he believes former president trump
should be held to account he did not say
the other day
whether or not they should take any
action against him after this trial does
go forward instead say
leave that out of the senate so forth
now here comes the briefing and uh
we'll talk about it then there jake
hi everyone happy tuesday a couple of
things to just update you on
on the top as we've discussed previously
in this room the president and the
administration are making the case
directly to the country
about the need to pass the rescue plan
so we can finish the job and get two
thousand dollars into the pockets of
working families
so we can reopen schools safely and so
we can get economic relief to struggling
americans and communities
as part of that work the president the
vice president and treasury secretary
yellen will meet this afternoon with
business leaders to discuss the vital
role
that the american rescue plan will play
in saving our economy
and getting americans back to work
private sector leaders
understand how important it is and we've
seen calls from across the political
spectrum
from leading business groups to labor
and progressive lawmakers
for congress to act quickly in getting
additional economic relief
out the door these calls have been
echoed by leading experts and economists
who have praised the plan
including top economic advisers to the
last four presidents
both democrat and republican an analysis
after analysis has shown that the
economic costs of an action would be
incredibly
painful for the american people
something we saw last friday with the
latest month of week job numbers
but they also know that we have a way to
help workers and get our economy back by
passing the rescue plan so a couple of
pieces of economic data you all may have
seen
a cbo projection last week found that it
would take the economy four years to
bounce back
and return to full employment without
the rescue plan studies by the brookings
institution
and moody's analytics found that the
economy could recover from the pandemic
and return to full employment by the
beginning of next year if the rescue
plan is enacted
moody's also found that passing the
passing the rescue plan would double
economic growth returning the economy to
full employment a full year
faster a couple of other updates from
our cova team you may have also seen
this
uh jeff science the covid coordinator
made a few announcements earlier this
afternoon
today we announced the launch of our
federal quality health centers
fqhc vaccination program community
health centers provide primary care
services in underserved areas
reaching almost 30 million people under
this new program
we will begin directly sending vaccine
to plot supply to community health
centers
enabling them to vaccinate more of the
people they serve
alongside other efforts like mobile
health units and community vaccination
centers
this announcement is another tool we are
providing to state and local leaders
in their work to reach underserved and
hardest hit populations importantly
this program grew in part out of a
suggestion uh from house committee
chairs
uh that the president had of course had
a meeting with them on friday but even
discussions
prior to that and he informed them
during a call this morning that this
program
would be rolled out uh
let's see last few pieces uh we also
announced another increase in weekly
vaccine
allocations to states tribes and
territories bringing us up to 11 million
doses so overall uh this after weekly
increases the past two weeks and it's a
net 28
increase two states since we entered
government
these announcements convey our steady
drumbeat of progress and action by the
federal government
and our whole of government pandemic
response
the president also will meet with
members of the covet response team in
the oval office today
to discuss their work and the next steps
in shutting down the virus
and getting american life back to normal
last thing i've noted a number of times
and some of you have asked about
our progress and efforts on
confirmations we're pleased to see
dennis mcdonough confirmed last night
with 87 yes votes
as the new secretary of veterans affairs
and he of course is being sworn in
today uh we also would uh just like to
reiterate
the importance of uh getting the uh our
nominee the president's nominee to lead
the department of education
miguel cardona confirmed obviously at a
time where
uh the american people are focused on
the reopening of schools
focus on focused on doing that safely
this is a step that congress could take
he's obviously a pivotal and key partner
and ensuring we can get that done
swiftly and safely uh with that alex
let's kick it off i wanted to ask you at
the top about the attempted hacking
and poisoning of the old smart florida
water supply
um does the white house have any details
on who committed the hacking
and is there any plan for review of
water supply stations
across the nation or an effort to shore
up those
the cyber security measures at those
stations
well uh as was uh announced earlier
today the fbi and secret service of
course are undergoing an investigation
uh that's something we'd certainly defer
to them on any specific details of their
findings of that investigation i will
say broadly speaking that
the president the vice president members
of our national security team are
focused on elevating cyber security as a
threat that has
only increased over the past several
years that's why they've made it
an across a government focus
on why he has elevated positions in the
white house and other parts of our
government
and then can you share any details on
the president's
visit to the department of defense what
we'll be discussing very often
sure uh the president will visit the
pentagon tomorrow
uh where he will thank the men and women
serving our country and keeping the
american people safe
as the first president in 40 years with
a child who served in the military
he has a personal connection to the
important role of
the of the work of the military the men
and women who serve
he will also discuss the vital role of
the department of defense and our
national security
talk about the significance of having
the first
secretary of defense in history leading
the department the visit has special
resonance coming during black history
month
over 40 percent of active duty forces
are men
and women of color and you will hear
president biden pay special tribute to
the rich
history of black service members
tomorrow
any new policy relapse tomorrow
he will certainly as i noted talk about
the important role of the defense
department
in our national security but uh we will
have more to
uh share about that um as we get closer
to his visit
go ahead oh let's go jeff reuters i
promised you go ahead
thanks uh can you tell us how the
ceos were chosen for today's meeting of
president biden
um i see some diversity in that group
which isn't always common at the top
echelons of
corporate america was that one of the
far too uncommon
yes is that one of the factors and how
how did you go about choosing that
well first i would expect that this is
the first of many engagements the
president will have
directly with leaders from the business
community and
this was an opportunity to speak
directly with some who are
major employers in the country some who
are
leading the business roundtable or other
organizational kind of business groups
where they speak to many
business leaders across the country so
this is an opportunity to have a
smaller meeting it's only about half a
dozen as you know and discussion about
the american rescue plan
uh how it will impact workers and
american families and
how they can work together to get people
back on their feet specifically walmart
jp morgan what what is the president's
ask of those types of companies for this
i wouldn't look at it through that prism
jeff i would look at it as a
conversation with
um leaders who uh have um
uh you know walmart is of course one of
the biggest employers in the country and
states across the country
uh obviously jamie dimon is somebody who
um has been in the business sector for
many many years uh so it's more of a
discussion about
um the country and the economic downturn
that we've gone through
president wants to lay out all of the
specifics of his plan
hear feedback from them as he ha as he
has with uh
many different groups over the past
couple of weeks just one other econ
related question
did the white house ask omb director
nominee
mira tandon to apologize to republicans
in her testimony this morning and
how confident are you about that
nomination now
well the president wouldn't nominate
anyone he wasn't confident could get
confirmed
and didn't deserve the consideration and
confirmation of
uh of his of senate uh democrats and
republicans
um we certainly did not ask her to
make any specific comments in her
testimony today
uh go ahead kristen thank you a couple
of questions on the impeachment of
the copen package that president biden
is proposing first on impeachment
today there's going to be a debate over
the constitutionality
of the process whether it's
constitutional to try and try to remove
from office of former president
does president biden have any concerns
that this trial could set
a dangerous precedent for the
institution of the presidency
well uh president biden uh we put out a
statement uh
following the conclusion of the house
vote just a couple of weeks ago
and he made clear in that statement that
he felt the process should proceed as
uh as uh history uh you know and and
many
laws uh predetermined uh and he is
going to wait for the senate to
determine the outcome of this but
uh you know his view is that his role is
should be currently focused on
addressing the needs of the american
people putting people back to work
addressing the pandemic
i don't think that's for me or us to
opine on obviously he said that the
process should proceed and it's doing
exactly that
let me ask you as millions of people
tune in to watch this
trial presumably throughout the week
they're going to see
the former president's lawyers argue
based on the briefs that they have filed
that some democrats have used incendiary
rhetoric they are going to point to
representative maxine waters for example
who in 2018
called on supporters at a rally to
confront and at one point harass
trump officials over their support of
the child separation policy
the zero tolerance policy um that's
something that cedric richmond
said she had a constitutional right to
express those views
so how does the white house view that as
any different
look the president is joe biden is the
president he's not a pundit
he's not going to opine on the back and
forth arguments
nor is he watching them that are taking
place in the senate
let me ask you about the covert relief
package yesterday
the ways and means committee democrats
proposed
limiting the 1400 direct payments
to those making 75 000 or less is that
something
that president biden supports and does
he have any concerns that
progressives might not be on board with
that well the president has conveyed
uh from the beginning of this discussion
that he's open to having a discussion
about the thresholds uh he has been firm
in his resolve that americans should
be made whole on the two thousand dollar
checks which of course would mean
uh uh be maintaining his firmness on the
fourteen hundred dollar checks right
but there's been a discussion about the
thresholds and what those should look
like and he doesn't feel that
uh families making over 250 000 a year
should be the target of this relief but
there is a scale
up right in even in the recent
negotiations from
the 75 and from the 150 it's just
uh will reach a certain uh top threshold
where people would not receive relief
has he determined whether he would
support that does he support 75 000 as
being the threshold
it's not the threshold that's uh that's
kind of who would receive the maximum
amount there's been a scale up beyond
that uh these negotiations are
are ongoing uh we supportedly certainly
support uh the discussions as as they're
happening and certainly
his view is that these should be he's
open to the discussion about making them
more targeted and ensuring that people
who need relief
relief the most receive the relief go
ahead um
i had a couple but i wanted to follow up
on something jeff asked which was
dimon is among those participants and
there's been
complaints both that uh big banks like
jp morgan
have made it difficult for small
businesses minority businesses to access
epp
loans and lots of data that shows
recently
big banks have been scaling back
consumer lending and
instead buying government securities and
so
i know that this is kind of a
cheerleading event for the president's
legislative package but is he going to
raise either of those issues
with jamie dimon well um the president
does not have a litmus test that he uh
that he gives people before he meets
with them in the oval office otherwise
he would not have met with 10
republicans last week
so they don't agree with him on
everything i'm sure the business leaders
would convey that to you
he doesn't agree with them on everything
but this is really a discussion about
the american rescue plan
a plan that will help uh spark
economic growth help put people back to
work help get our economy and a path to
recovery and hopefully that's something
they can all agree on
and i know that you guys have put
together a task force to look at
domestic extremism
following what happened in january but
there's been a lot of reporting about
the breakdowns that have happened in the
government
out of that coordination between dhs and
the fbi and capitol police
so i'm wondering especially as there's
chatter indicating that there might be
further
sort of demonstrations surrounding the
election
what if anything the administration is
going to surrounding which
which election sorry i'm just trying to
follow the past one the past one
yes okay there's there have been there's
been online chatter that there's gonna
be another demonstration of march
here in washington my point is is the
administration doing anything
to look at the kind of breakdown that
happened within
law enforcement and the federal
government ahead of january 6 to make
sure that it's not replicated in the
future
well i think one of the steps we took
was the president
named a head of homeland security in the
white house that
a role that did not exist in the prior
administration who can serve in a
coordinating role to ensure that we are
in touch with state and local
authorities and officials something that
wasn't happening at
a pace um and with with the level of
coordination that should have happened
uh in the last administration
we obviously came into office or the
president came into office and our
entire national security team did at a
at a time of heightened alert
even on the day of the inauguration and
following so
i would say we certainly are not looking
to the past administration as a model
um and we are charting our own path to
make sure we do things differently
the world health organization said today
that it was
extremely unlikely that the chronovirus
escaped the lab in lupon
um and i'm just wondering especially now
that we've uh
sort of resumed our participation the
whole administration agrees with that um
assessment yeah we have uh obviously
seen those reports as i mean the public
reporting on it
we're looking forward to receiving the
report and the data from the who
investigation we haven't looked at the
data specifically ourselves
so we'd like to do that we've expressed
our concerns
regarding the need for full transparency
and access from china
and the who to all information regarding
the earliest days
of the pandemic but we weren't involved
directly in the implementation of this
investigation
and again we'll just look forward to
reviewing the findings in detail uh go
ahead
i will come back to you calendar go
ahead two questions on schools you're
not talking about reopening schools as
being a priority for the administration
are there any discussions within the
administration of providing these kind
of rapid tests that are being produced
by
volume and other companies to help that
move quicker to get those tests
to local uh to local school systems
within the states
well our focus really at this point in
time is
waiting for the cdc guidelines to come
out and give schools across the country
school districts across the country
the first medical and scientific
recommendations and guidelines that have
been given from the federal level
and obviously once those are put out
publicly
and concluded we will look for ways to
work with states to ensure that schools
are getting the resources they need
that's part of why we proposed funding
in the american rescue plan
but we want to wait to see what the
health and medical experts uh have in
those guidelines to ensure we're
directing those resources in the right
way or
working with states to do exactly that
secondly on president biden's
transgender rights executive action
specifically when it applies to high
school sports
uh what message would the white house
have for trans girls and cis girls
who may end up competing against each
other
in sparking some lawsuits and some
concern
among parents so there's a mystery to
have guidance for schools on dealing
with disputes rising over
trans girls competing against them with
cis girls i'm not sure what your
question is
the president's executive order i'm
familiar with the order but what was
your question about the question is
does the president have a message for
local school officials on dealing with
these kind of disputes that are already
starting to arise
between uh you know trans
girls who are competing and cis girls
and a level playing field
particularly in high school sports when
it leads to college scholarships is
there any kind of messaging
or clarification the white house wants
to give on the executive order
i would just say that the president's
belief is that uh trans rights are human
rights
and that's why he signed that executive
order and in terms of the determinations
by universities and colleges i would
certainly defer to them
uh go ahead and oh sorry caitlyn go
ahead go ahead and then we go to the
back go ahead
okay i don't mind when you call me i
have three quick questions
um one on what democrats have put
forward with these stimulus checks it's
not changing the income cap so instead
of
uh limiting it from the 75 thousand
dollars to get the full fourteen hundred
dollars that's staying where it is
biden had said president biden said he
was open to targeting that so
did he sign off on what the democrats
have now put forward
you mean uh where the cap stops or where
the the threshold stops at the top the
cap stops for the full
fourteen hundred dollars right now it's
seventy five thousand dollars as opposed
to
fifty thousand or what others like joe
manchin had proposed so did he sign off
on
the latest proposal from them yesterday
well his proposal was originally
75 right and 150. and he's open to
targeting
which it which it still will be targeted
because it's about the question of
of what the threshold goes up to right
because prior
uh in in earlier proposals it had a
higher threshold where it went up to a
higher income level for families
where they would get some version of a
check not the fourteen hundred dollars
right but a smaller version so not
bringing
down that cap at the 75 000 to a fifty
thousand dollars
he he supports that um where the status
of the negotiations is at this point yes
of the seventy five thousand dollars
okay my second question is we had the
acting attorney general
ask all of the trump appointed u.s
attorneys to resign from their post
with the exception of two the one
overseeing the beginnings of the russia
probe and the one
overseeing hunter biden's tax pro can
you comment on that
uh as you know this has been commonplace
among previous administrations
and we look forward to working with the
senate to swiftly fill these openings in
the coming weeks the president has also
made clear
that he wants to restore the
independence of the department of
justice and to ensure it remains
free of any undue political influence
that will be helped when our attorney
is of course confirmed but the decision
to leave two u.s attorneys
in their roles is a reflection of that
commitment okay so he had no
conversations with the acting attorney
general about the two who remained in
their post
uh in what way you mean who like who
would leave
didn't have any conversation did he have
any conversations with the acting
attorney general about leaving the
u.s attorney in delaware and connecticut
in their post
these were decisions that were made in
order to fulfill his promise of
maintaining independence
and ensuring that uh he sent that
message in every action that was taken
okay and my last question i know you
said the president is not abundant
i think we all under agree with that
understand that but he
is the first president to be in office
and have a former president his
predecessor go
and face an impeachment trial just down
the street so
how can he not weigh in on whether or
not it's constitutional given he is
the current office holder and we have
the questions of what precedent this
sets and whether or not he agrees that
it's constitutional
well again this is obviously a big story
in the country no one's denying that
here and there's certainly going to be a
lot of attention and focus on it but
our focus and the president's focus is
on putting people back to work getting
the pandemic under control and that
means we're not going to
weigh in on every question about the
impeachment trial and we don't feel it's
uh necessary or our role to do that
go ahead a couple topics i'll get
through them quick the cbo is projecting
that uh raising the
federal minimum wage to 15 an hour would
lift 900 000 people out of poverty but
it would cost
1.4 million jobs that is a difference of
a half a million people what happens to
them
of the well i i would also say that in
the cbo
uh cbo uh findings i should say
uh that they've also concluded that 27
million american workers uh
would uh millions of low weight major
wage workers i should say 27 million
american workers
would uh would be able to uh get would
help get them out of poverty
um so there's a huge impact of raising
the minimum wage uh
it's that's why the president supports
it uh there are also
many other economic studies that show
that raising the minimum wage has
minimal impact on employment a study of
u.s state level minimum wage changes
over four decades found that the number
of jobs remains
essentially unchanged over the five
years following the increase so
the president supports it because he
believes that
then raising the minimum wage is
something that american workers american
families deserve
and that lifting 27 million american
workers
uh out of poverty reducing inequality
would be a
very positive step for our country and
once there is an agreement
does president biden support sending
stimulus
benefits to undocumented immigrants
again i don't if if somebody has a
social security number like a child
or a spouse then they would be eligible
but he supports
uh sending benefits to people who are
eligible as a part of his proposal
okay and then on transparency i have a
very specific question about executive
order
one three eight nine one uh one of the
president's executive orders
on the first day revoked a policy that
required
federal agencies to post their guidance
on a searchable
database uh there are questions down on
capitol hill from some republican
senators about
why that was revoked and so now the
question to you
well um agencies have definitely not
been told
uh to take down databases or other
public information
that would be inconsistent which i think
is why you're asking the question with
what the president has talked about what
the vice president talked about
we want uh agencies to use all the tools
available to them to make public
policies transparent accessible
uh however this executive order was
revoked because it created unnecessary
hurdles
and cumbersome processes for agencies
that wanted to get guidance out to the
public
in some cases it was uh resulting in the
delay of information going out more
publicly
by a couple of weeks or even a couple of
months that's obviously not acceptable
and
uh we want it to be more efficient than
that and one quick one on conflicts of
interest and some reporting that's been
done
uh by our colleagues at other networks
the president's son-in-law
dr howard crime was advising candidate
biden
on copenhagen response while he was
investing
in companies involved with the kobe 19
response through
his company startup health dr crime
has been at the white house since the
inauguration
is he still advising the president on
copenhagen response
will dr crine is his son-in-law um the
president
there are questions about a potential
well and i think he was here because the
president was inaugurated recently which
is
understandable uh the president has made
clear that there will be an absolute
wall between him and any businesses
connected with his family members
and as he reiterated just last week no
family member is going to have an office
in the white house or be involved in any
government policy making
that applies to his son-in-law and
applies to every single member of his
family
just from a broad perspective though
like the 30 000 foot view of this
candidate biden was very concerned
about the last president's potential
conflicts of interest at one point in
2019 he tweeted
hosting the g7 at trump's hotel a
president should never be able to use
the office
for personal gain so how is the white
house going to guarantee
to members of the public that nobody in
the family is using the office for
personal gains
we've put in place stringent policies in
order to ensure that it is not being
used for personal gain
there is not a single member of the
family who is employed at the white
house will have an office in the white
house or
uh will benefit uh financially and those
are strict
uh ethics requirements that have been
put in place and the president has
approved
uh go ahead thank you two questions uh
one on the president's stimulus package
you've been arguing uh
consistently that uh his goal of unity
doesn't mean creating one party
on and you also point out that there are
polls
supporting what he's trying to get out
there
but what is his bottom line for showing
that he has really tried the unity would
it be one republican sense would be
enough
would zero be enough like would he be
happy if no
republican senators support his bill i
guess that's what it boils down to
well he the president is certainly
hopeful that
uh the process that's underway now the
markups that are happening in the house
the markups
that will then proceed in the senate
will provide an opportunity for
republicans uh democrats of all
different political stripes to put
their ideas forward and have those ideas
considered at the end of the day
his view is that urgency uh is uh
his first priority here and that the
american people
uh people who are concerned about
getting food on the table one in seven
american families
people who are worried about reopening
schools and getting their kids back in
the classroom
people worried about whether their
grandmother and their cousin are going
to get vaccines
that's where his priority is so uh the
question really is if
70 70 74 depending on the poll of
americans including the majority of
republicans in some polls
support this proposal uh support the
components of this proposal then why
aren't more republicans supporting it we
certainly hope
they will and and welcome them uh to the
table
uh go ahead in the back this is
literally a housekeeping question okay
um president trump former president
trump
he broke tradition by not having his
predecessor had a portrait hanged up
here
um that as far as i understand that was
something that was considered
totally the normal thing to do will
president biden be inviting his
predecessor to hang up a portrait
somewhere
and will he get the obamas back in to
finally get their you know their
ceremony
i have no portrait revealings or
portrait plans or portrait events to
preview for you
um but i have not been given any
indication that we would break with
tradition in that regard
uh go ahead this is distinctly not
an impeachment question but okay it can
be an impeachment question you can ask
whatever you want go ahead
thank you does the president believe
that former president
trump engaged in insurrection as
described
in section 3 of the 14th amendment the
president has put out multiple
statements
conveying that what the president did
and his words and his
actions uh were and of course the events
of january 6th
uh were a a threat to our democracy
uh but he ran against him because he was
concerned
that former president trump was unfit
for office
in part because of his past history of
invoking violence around the country so
he's president trump is not here because
former president trump is not here
because president biden
defeated him the more of the american
people voted for him and now his
focus is on delivering on his promises
to the american people
where does the president stand on an
effort in california to recall gavin
newton
i i have not i have not spoken with the
president about uh the reported the
recall i should say or the efforts to
recall
former governor newsom obviously he is
somebody who
he has been engaged with in the past
they have a range of uh
issues they have common agreement on
from the need to address climate change
to put people back to work
to address the covid crisis uh and
uh you know we we remain closely engaged
with him in his office go ahead
you i've got a quick personnel question
and then two follow-ups
um about a year ago in march uh
president biden said
that beto o'rourke would be helping him
uh when it came to his push for gun
control does
mr o'rourke have any official role here
at the white house or has the president
discussed anyone
with him uh he doesn't have any official
role uh obviously
the president uh spoke that back then
during the campaign and i know still has
admiration for the role
um that uh bitter work played in
elevating the issue of gun violence and
the need for gun safety measures but
i don't have any personnel announcements
to make um and then
you talked about hopes for transparency
from china and you you talked about the
need to get that data from the world
health organization
earlier in the pandemic um you know you
know april and may
there was a lot of criticism that the
world health organization
was praising china for its transparency
at a moment when china certainly wasn't
are there any type of reforms now that
the united states has rejoined
the president biden would like to see
from the world health organization
well um you know one of the reasons of
course that we
want to take a look at the data
ourselves is because we were not
involved in the planning and
implementation of the investigation
we also feel of course we support we
rejoined the world health organization
but
that it's imperative that we have our
own team of experts on the ground
in our embassy in beijing and otherwise
to make sure we have eyes and ears on
the ground
uh but i don't have any more reforms or
anything to announce for you at this
point in time
and then um back to the cbo report that
peter was asking a second ago is there a
specific
plan for anyone who would lose their job
if the minimum wage is increased or is
it just
a hope that cbo is wrong about those
numbers well remember that the
plan the american rescue plan why there
was a score of any component of it
would put millions of people to work and
that is also something that outside
economists and many
studies have shown and so our whole
objective here is to
make sure i should i should say make
sure we are getting people the
assistance they need
make sure we are putting vaccines in the
arms of americans and make sure we are
um you know reopening schools and let me
just remedy something i just said
the president is going to roll out a
build back better agenda a jobs package
in the coming weeks heart part of his
objective is combined with this package
to make sure we are not only addressing
the pandemic but we are also
reinvigorating the economy so his goal
with all of these plans is to work with
congress to put people back to work
and the minimum wage increasing the
minimum wage is a way to ensure that
workers are pulled out of poverty that
millions of workers who are
making you know doing honest work and
making it
um you know making an honest living are
not living on the poverty line he thinks
that's
right and that's something that should
happen but he has had no shortage of
proposals to put people back to work and
part of the reason
this was scored is because uh he's
starting to put proposals for it go
ahead huns
uh just two questions one the first one
the full question from a colleague in
canada
and that is that canada has announced
that it will require covet negative
tests for anyone crossing the land
border in the united states
does the u.s plan to reciprocate i don't
have any additional travel restrictions
to
read out for you obviously our cova team
and our health and medical experts
make recommendations based on what is
necessary to keep people safe and they
put in place some travel restrictions
but i don't have anything to
preview for you or predict on the canada
land
crossing front okay uh and then you
mentioned the
sort of goal of opening up schools
swiftly and safely
could you help us understand what the
white house is or what the president's
definition of open schools is does it
mean teachers
in classroom teaching students in
classroom does it just mean
kids in classroom with a remote screen
help us understand
sure his goal that he set is to have the
majority of schools so more than 50
percent
open uh by day 100 of his presidency and
that means
some teaching in classrooms so at least
one day a week hopefully it's more and
obviously it is
as much as is safe in each school and
local district
when you say some teaching that's you
didn't use the same majority qualifier
there you just have to have some
teaching
in school some teachers in school not
the majority of teachers in school in
the majority of classrooms
well teaching at least one day a week um
in the majority of schools by day 100
okay and that's in person teaching in
person teaching yes
sure go ahead oh go ahead
thank you um another studio question the
report that came out yesterday said that
the first four months
of fiscal year 2021 the federal deficit
rose 90
to 738 billion dollars obviously we've
seen economists saying that it's better
to do too much than nothing at all
but republicans are expected for
expressing sticker shock so i was
curious what the president's plan was
to decrease the deficit once the
pandemic
has abated and the economy is stabilized
well
uh one thing that could happen is that
the tax cuts for the highest income
could be rolled back
um and there's kind of a newfound
concern about deficit reduction
among some who supported those tax cuts
so um
you know that's one suggestion but the
reason that the president
and members of his economic team feel
that uh
this a package of this size is so
essential at this moment
is because uh we are dealing with a
pandemic
we are dealing with an economic downturn
people are suffering the american people
need assistance and this emergency
relief
is something that um the cost of doing
nothing or the cost of doing too little
is the greater risk and his view and the
view of
many economists and including his uh
secretary of treasury
thank you jen oh thank you everyone i
know you have to go we'll to do this
again tomorrow
me